Podcast the San Francisco Sketchfest you
also I'll be there
January 31st live crab feast podcast at
riot La February 6th I'll be up at the
High Line in Seattle with crab feast you
know it's all about JUCO goes Jay Lawson
self-diagnose go down low this week last
week here we go again for crab feast
[Music]
welcome back to the crab fees get to
sleep no the to the crown fees for that
yeah hey welcome oh my god that was that
was healthy that was healthy Pitt went
full for it and I just didn't have it
man you went I felt like I was concerned
as I thought you were gonna keep going
and then all of a sudden you just jumped
out of it man it was happy here and I
did I took us to like thirty sixty
thousand feet like friends go and then
that I was like exploding diet coke sub
Lake beast the nation you know I'm proud
to be a part of you glad to be a part of
this
LT comedy in the house Jay Larson comedy
as my old website is Jay Larson comedy
Jay Larson can become jealous and comedy
all social media a bunch of dates that
are on my website right doesn't like me
to list them off he thinks it takes too
much time I don't think yeah I mean you
made a little are they posted yet of
course it posts but the Improv a bunch
told you guys that'll be it sketch fest
with this jackass doing a live podcast
he'll tell you about it and the the
cartoon show I'll be doing up there as
well and then Honolulu Hawaiian Brian's
on the 30th if you're on an island hop
on over to the big one
cuz I'm pretty I don't know if it's the
big ones but that's where I'll be a
Honolulu so come up there in the 30th
and then one more show I want to tell
you about that's gonna be great
on the 2nd of February the day before my
birthday I'll be at the Comedy Store
in the main room doing a great show that
I'm really excited about in a little
nervous that show gets me a little
nervous
what's show Sara Mello show she's doing
a great show over there monthly and then
on the 24th of February at the meltdown
also looking forward to that so come on
out to any of those sickle cell Ryan
Sickler on Twitter and Instagram Ryan
Sickler official on Facebook Ryan
Sickler com
Jay mentioned January 23rd live craf e's
podcast the san francisco sketch fest
you also I'll be there
January 31st live craft fees podcast at
riot LA February 6th I'll be up at the
High Line in Seattle with Macbeth and
court come out and see us we can't wait
to see you all and
February 16th live crab feast podcast
the Hollywood improv with our guests on
Affairs we are doing a monthly live
graphics podcast the third Tuesday of
every month love the year at the
Hollywood improv lab we're very excited
to to be there we did one in December
that was a lot of fun and this is our
first of the year there on February 16
come out have some fun with us we're
gonna have a good time that was one of
our New Year's resolutions I feel like I
know that we didn't say it was but we've
been talking about doing a resident live
podcast and now we're doing it yeah we
got it and thank you to the Hollywood
improv and Jamie flame over there for
making that happen
if you put it into the world it actually
exists it actually does exist tickets
for all shows on Ryan Sickler com the
crab feast calm thank you always thank
you for the buying the merch and wearing
it supporting it sending us pictures of
it I love seeing you around the world
Amazon monthly help is so fantastic of
all of you yeah if anyone out there
isn't used that Amazon link put it in
your browser click through boom boom
that's how you can help you can help
it's a free donation if you're shopping
on Amazon already and have used the
Amazon now all I do is Prime I don't go
anywhere anymore
no I'm talking about Amazon now no was
that the word get there in a day no the
other day we ordered guess how long it
took to get here how long 36 minutes
come on I swear to God somewhere what do
you mean dude they got like a warehouse
we we sat down one to watch a movie
didn't have a DVD player you know we did
Amazon now is there in 45 minutes some
dude showed up at the door I swear to
God looking around left or right real
quick like just give me just give me 28
bucks for it yeah
so there's your premium episodes
available for iTunes and androids
Facebook Fanpage
the iTunes page five star reviews are
the funniest thing on the internet
written and then make sure you follow
all things comedy on social media back
again Squarespace we're excited to have
them I know I think we talked about it
before but I had to build my own website
one time and it was a joke dude remember
my brother had me like dude what is this
it's ridiculous and I just decided that
point I'm like you need someone to do it
and you don't want to hire some because
it's too expensive
squarespace man their sites look
professionally designed regardless of
your skill level right because they
allow you to look good yeah you just put
it in there no coding required
it's intuitive and easy to use tools
which that's what you need to get things
done and get a free domain if you sign
up for a year you listen if you ain't
serious don't sign up don't get it at
all so you're gonna need at least for a
year anyway make it part of your new
year's resolution to get something going
now start your free trial today your
free trial today at squarespace.com when
you decide to sign up it's Squarespace
make sure to use offer code craft fees
to get 10% off your first purchase
Squarespace build it beautiful
you like my read didn't you I love let's
tie it up right now with I guess this
week excited to have him on another
first-timer man we've been bringing out
a lot of first-timers a lot of virgins
on the crab feast excited to have me
here please welcome Tom Rhodes
welcome to the crash thanks for all this
delicious crap thanks for busting our
balls about half of that it's so good to
have you here man I know the fans have
been saying it for a while so we're glad
we could make it happen you've been
getting a lot of requests people have
hit us up about having you seriously I'm
you'll see our fans are the best fans
they absolutely have them and they make
good best fans don't let them down don't
you better deliver the goods buddy
before we get started why don't you tell
everyone my name is rose and I'm a
Capricorn and my favorite color is blue
what kind of blue like navy like
midnight blue thanks for saying that
you know the shade before purple yeah
yeah you know yeah that's a fun way to
introduce yourself I like blue what kind
of the shade before the darkest blue is
like drift off marine blue I think it's
also called electric blue there is
something about a midnight blue you know
when there's a bright star against it
you know what I mean it's good I took my
son out the other night to look at the
moon I'm like yeah that's true the moon
has been pretty yeah it really uh
driving last night to a show I'm going
down and downtown was right here and the
moon was it looked like Gotham and it
was early so the city was still lit up
like they were so cleaning or people
working late
grinding the midnight hour you know what
I mean um you took your son downtown is
now this was another time I took him out
this morning the wind man guys was
gnarly
you have to share your Halloween candy
with the homeless PETA mouse down to
skid row why don't you Twitter website
my twitter is at underscore Tom Rhodes
my website is Tom Rhodes net and your
podcast Tom Rhodes radio saying you can
find that on the all things comedy
network just like us you and I perfect
who had Tom Rhodes Tom Rose there is a
excuse me there's a real estate mogul in
Dallas Texas and he got Tom Rhodes calm
son of a fed 1999 I didn't even have a
computer until 2000 in 1999 this guy
registered Tom Rhodes calm Tom Rhodes
net Tom Rhodes TV Tom Rhodes everything
so originally my first podcast my first
website was Rhodes world mm-hmm because
I grew up in Orlando everything's world
haha get it
excuse me these nicotine lozenges are
killing my throat he is such a nice guy
I wrote him a letter and I asked him if
I said first of all let me compliment
you on what a wonderful name I think you
have nice and then I [ __ ] split them
well you just sold last week and then I
asked him if he would be willing to give
up Tom Rhodes net and he's a really
magnanimous wonderful guy and why
wouldn't he be his name is Tom Rhodes he
said and he didn't charge me any money
and he said all I ask is free tickets
for life every time you play Dallas so
has he come out ever he has come out
once and actually I'm there next week so
that reminds me I need to contact this
guy and let him know let him know ya
know right now other taro
I thought that was very uncooperative
you know heartless thing to do did he I
mean he charged me twenty five hundred
yeah he dished gotten that out though
huh yeah that's nice he came to see in
support yeah that's that's well done Tom
Rhodes good dude that's good man he had
foresight two men grabbin he did 99 dog
man got the internet started I'm like 96
I feel like he was on that she got dot
e-d-u and then started in elementary
school when when did you guys first have
a website my first website was 2000 mine
was I started comedy in 2001 and my
brother was in web design and so I hit
my brother up like a year and a half
maybe 2003 I got one 2004 and my brother
made this like insane web site for me
and it had flash and all these things
and then like I had had it for like a
month and a half and I hit my brother up
I'm like hey man can you update my I got
some dates I want to put on there he's
like dude I can't be updating this thing
for you all I'm like because I you know
I mean it was like you to program
everything says homepage yeah it was
like a wordpress I had a lot of stoner
people helping me with my originally web
original websites that just took forever
to get anything updated on it these
started in 99 they got done like oh one
yeah you know yeah that's why I good
with that you should never have like
friends or family do your pod your
website yeah or podcast or potkins damn
about that good lord
so speaking of friends and family you
started telling us a little bit about
your dad before we started and that's he
sounds very interesting well he tell us
a little bit about him my dad my parents
are from Anacostia Washington it's a
neighborhood in Washington DC which is
now and where Washington DC I thought I
heard an are in there for a second I was
like uh it's like it's like the the
blackest neighborhood in Washington DC
now but along in the 50s it was still
like white people and immigrants and
things
but my dad flew helicopters in Vietnam
my father actually volunteered for
Vietnam and he flew helicopters he was
shot down and after he died I read the
letter from the Army there was like 20
guys on the ground surrounded by
Vietcong just getting slaughtered and my
dad's helicopter made three attempts to
get down and save these guys and then
they got and there's so much heavy fire
they had to circle around three times
the fourth attempt they get down all
these guys jump on the helicopter
because it's life or death
and then as it was pulling up it took so
much fire that it knows tail down right
to the ground and everyone died except
for my dad and his co-pilot who he
unhooked and dragged across a field
under heavy fire and then they had to
wait there for like two or three hours
before someone could get them out and my
dad got like five medals for it yeah
yeah and then I was telling you got
killed by a drunk driver
in 2009 and he's buried in Arlington
National Cemetery so let me add how many
give any brothers or sisters
yeah I have two older brothers and my
little sister died of breast cancer in
2000 what a happy podcast this thanks
for coming on this ey have you see why
I'm a comedian well we just so you know
every October we do a breast cancer
awareness thing and we donate money to
breast cancer so we're sorry to hear
that but we are on point with that but
what I want to know is like growing up I
dude like that I mean my buddy Phil's
dad was in Vietnam and he was like he
had a little fun sense of humor but when
it was time to lay down the law of this
dude lay down the law and he had moments
where he's just like like where's your
dad I was like he's in the basement
alone down there you know what I mean
like was your dad a lot more than that
yeah yeah yeah like you know yeah my dad
was a real badass tough guy but he had a
great sense of humor fortunately I had
two older brothers yeah who were monkey
mouth authority challengers and they got
you know they most of the conflict was
with them so my dad actually loved
comedy
and he had tons of comedy albums my dad
loved Richard Pryor really it's a lot
like your dad and my dad's the reason
I'm a comedian he took me to my first
comedy show in Washington DC when I was
12 years old
whoo it was a like an open mic night and
is 1978 so yeah I was 11 actually and
the place was called El Brookman and it
was a shotgun Shack style room and the
stage was next to the entrance and we
walked in and I had a Washington
Redskins jacket on and the comedian
onstage pulled me onstage and he
interviewed me shut like I was the coach
of the Redskins I all evil dopey one
more dancers you know like yes and no
ready to crush it but I'll never forget
standing on that stage and seeing all
those happy faces thrown back and
laughter and all the teeth in their
mouth and that moment changed my life
that's why I'm a comedian that's the
thing that is great yeah yeah and then
my dad also drove me to my first open
mic night when I was 17 did he stay and
watch yeah he did he did yeah of course
well you know you know when I had my
sitcom my dad was living in Anaheim and
he sat in the front row for every oh
yeah and I started out on the southern
circuits and my dad but also like
sometimes would just surprise me and
turn up and you know in Knoxville
Tennessee or somewhere know here in the
helicopter man you better move your car
babies are the War Room depart so what's
the was he like did he know your
material would he give you notes would
he well you know my my dad was an
insurance salesman mm-hmm so actually a
lot of the best comedy advice I was ever
given was from my dad
pertaining to sales like when I was
young a lot of young comedians you know
I wanted to be shocking and edgy right
so I would come out and I would do like
some like really sick joke up front like
the first joke out of my mouth and my
dad would go you can't do that he goes
there's an old saying in sales where
they'll buy from a friend before they
will a stranger mm-hmm so make friends
with them first and then do the
weird sick stuff later in your show I
mean that's that's such great advice I
mean not just for comedy but like I'm
just thinking like you want to an
audition if you just sit there and wait
to go and just do your lines fine but if
you joke around a little bit talk a
little bit you just warm people up in
anything like if you're trying to buy
something a yard sale you don't be like
how much you like oh this is crap and
then you're like how about $0.50 now I
have a friend that's in sales and he and
I talked about the parallel that he's
got when he walks into a place that that
he's new he's got the same amount of
time we do roughly 60 seconds to get
them to notice them and be on his side
and then it becomes here's what I'm
selling just like we're selling jokes
and humor he's selling whatever he's
selling is this we talk about it all the
time all the time yeah so that's so and
during the sitcom was he just like proud
as can be with the smile oh my god yeah
well we filmed the show at Universal
Studios mm-hmm and my dad really loved
that the gate the guards at the gate
knew who he was
and that they would just you know so
after the after the show was going about
three or four episodes he wouldn't have
to stop they were just like
give him a salute and lift the gate oh
and yeah he loved them of course he did
do that's I mean that's money in the
bank that's where you want to be getting
I mean I have a boy right now Rhys got a
daughter so like the idea of like I
never knew my didn't my dad wasn't
really around so having someone like
introduced my mom I saw Bill Cosby when
I was 10 like that was the first time I
say comedy but it was like my mom was a
comedy fan was like you gotta go see
Bill Cosby stand-up his storytelling is
amazing my mom was like put some in my
drink tonight come on no but like I
think my mom probably saw it is like oh
look this you know The Cosby Show what
you know this is Bill Cosby let me take
the kids go see Bill Cosby yeah but she
did it she didn't take you to Ice
Capades or no you know Joseph and the
Technicolor Dreamcoat or whatever it
rained a lot in the Old Testament but it
has never talked about but yeah my dad I
went to see Richard Pryor
Richard Pryor's 50th birthday he was at
the Comedy Store and I got tickets from
my dad and I rich Pryor was all eaten up
with MS and he's in a wheelchair and
they're some big guys had to lift him on
and he could barely hold the microphone
but I mean just to be in the same room
with Richard Pryor and my dad because
you know my dad had like you know he not
only had the vinyl records of Pryor he
had like the cassette tapes I remember
driving around in the car with my dad
listening to Pryor and like I didn't get
a lot of the you know adult dirty stuff
but all the stuff Pryor did about like
animating animals and things like that I
thought was hilarious all of it in case
you probably just resonated like it was
like you know because I mean I don't
wanna get too heady about it but I feel
like in comedy there's there's the joke
that you're coming out of your mouth and
then there's like whatever you're
radiating off your body that you're
trying to connect with people to get
them on the same page and you're gonna
get that through hearing it anyway you
know yeah I was that too much time no I
agree with you 100% I'm looking for crap
I I was the same way with Pryor my dad I
was a little kid I snuck down the stairs
my dad's watching this movie and I've
told this a bunch of times but I'm
sitting behind him in the hallway and I
see over shoulder this movie with kids
on the screen so I think kids I'm a kid
I'm probably allowed to watch this and
then I see Richard Pryor come on and
it's bustin loose where he's taking the
kids to the orphanage and I start
laughing so hard that I get caught and
he yells get in here and I'm like ah
[ __ ] and he said sit down watch the rest
of this movie with me and then that was
it and then he introduced me to Rodney
Dangerfield and George Carlin and good
dad knew Dangerfield yeah man ain't you
didn't get any respect either I was a
huge riot they vote that doctor pretty
moonbots both of us my problem is I
appeal to everyone who will do me
absolutely no good
[Laughter]
I love Draghi when I was 14 15 I just
worshipped Rodney Dangerfield and I knew
all of his albums by heart and then he
played in Orlando at the Tupperware
auditorium and it was a dome yeah yeah
yeah did love pop the roof but a friend
of mine John Forester and I went to see
Rodney Dangerfield I'm like 15 years old
we both knew all of the album by heart
all of his albums and Dangerfield was
drunk out of his mind
it was terrible he's screwing up the job
and it was a really bad show he's drunk
he's screwing up the lines and then
there was no security at this place the
show ended and my friend and I wanted to
meet Rodney Dangerfield so we snuck we
up on the stage and went on the side
behind the curtain and then it's all
black back there and then there was a
light in the back in the distance and we
headed towards the light and it was his
dressing room and we go back there and
he's sitting in his underwear and he's
he slumped over the table and he's got a
beer in front of him and then years
later I learned that that's an old that
was an old Catskill comedian trick where
when they got off stage they would take
their pants off immediately so that they
could preserve the dry-cleaning crease
the next show yeah yeah whatever it is
to preserve the the suit looking good so
we're like Rodney Rodney you're the best
man Rodney brought he signed this man
and then I got him to sign this piece of
paper and it wasn't even worth saving
because it was just like a wave of a pen
and anybody could have done it and then
his road manager comes hey kids what are
you doing here and like we're like we
love Rodney be loved Rodney goes look
you got to leave him alone get out of
here and they said look here's the
here's the the exit door you got to go
out here he said look he'll be coming
out here in a little bit and then you
can say hi to him as he's going out so
we're sitting there waited about a half
hour there's a waiting list and car to
take him back to his hotel or whatever
and then the door opens and Rodney
Dangerfield comes out and he is so drunk
he cannot navigate the three cement
steps from this deal Stage Door to the
waiting Lincoln Towncar and he goes hey
kids gimme an and he puts one and he
puts one arm around John Forester and
I'll never forget carrying this old
man's torso down these three cement
steps and then we gently placed him in
the back of the Lincoln Towncar as if he
were the baby Jesus lifted his wallet
man
the door closed and then he drove off
and it was at that moment I knew what I
wanted to do with it
if I could be some old drunk guy the
teenage guys loved and just will carry
that's amazing think about that though
if you're a comedian in your 60s and
fifteen-year-old love you love you I
would be sick by that like wow I'm
reaching your generation I'll never I
used to listen him and laugh all the
time with that [ __ ] like he's like I
came home the other day guys jogging
naked through my neighborhood I'm like
what do you do are you doing that he's
like because you came home early
he's not just back back I was in you
know I was like a like a sophomore in
high school and like I'd be like telling
my friends his joke you know my wife is
so fat when she sits around the house
she sits around and so like I'd be doing
these jokes and my friends would be like
you don't have a wife man you're 14 yeah
what do you talk he said get a brown
necktie I got right in the subway the
other day guy pulled a razor on me it
was my own fault I was standing too
close to an electro ball so I want to go
back because I mean I think it's beyond
impressive you said your father's buried
in Arlington I mean that that's I mean
that's the highest honor for a soldier
to be buried in Arlington yeah and it's
pretty full I don't you got to be a real
badass to get in there now and have you
been yeah when you have a family member
buried in Arlington you can sign up for
this family pass and you put it on your
windshield and you drive through it's in
my agenda so when I whenever I go to
washing
we've been there twice since and I've
wept like a baby I'm sure my dad was
always the life of the party he had a
really dark twisted sense of humor which
is I think where I get my dark twisted
sense of humor but he taught me when I
was very my dad's favorite drink was a
rusty nail which I even when I was
drinking I stopped drinking a year and a
half ago I could never drink scotch
Shambu a scotch scotch and Drambuie and
so he taught me how to make it the way
he liked it with just the right amount
of ice the right amount of scotch and
Drambuie and then how to stir it and so
I would always make them for you know
make me a made me a rusty nail yes what
was the Scotch like cutty sark or
something like that yeah he like yeah
that you guessed it that was a good one
never like really expensive ones but and
so when I go to his grave I hit a liquor
store and I buy him on a little glass
tumbler great I get the little cocktail
glass you know buy a bag ice and I'll
get the man and I'll make it for him and
I so I've been there twice and I've left
it and then broke yeah and then there's
a weird thing should I tell this about
the yeah so my dad I lived in Anaheim
and then this it was is it's a long
convoluted story this rich guy who
actually got off for this is the driver
a drunk driver who hit him
he was in the hospital for like three
months he's really screwed up the this
drunk driver hit him his minivan and it
flipped a few times ended up in a ditch
so he's in the hospital for like three
months and I went to visit him and he
was sick of the hospital food so he
asked me if I would go to McDonald's and
get him a Big Mac meal and an apple pie
and so I have a Pie's tight so I went
and got it and I forgot the apple pie I
I had the greatest relationship with my
dad you know my brother's had some
issues with him I don't think they ever
resolved I was really close with my dad
we had a great relationship and it's
funny when someone you really love in
life dies like the little goofy [ __ ]
that you think about and I we didn't
have any unresolved issues or anything
except Timon I [ __ ] think I forgot
the [ __ ] apple pie and it drives me
crazy so the two times I've gone to his
grave
at Arlington I will bring him make him a
rusty nail and I put it on his grave and
then I also put a McDonald's apple pie
oh my god
I so if you ever walk into Arlington and
you see a little cocktail and an apple
pie you know that's my dad's grave and
that I was there recently yeah I my
father died also my dad died when I was
16 and I that you talked about the funny
what what you hold on to so I my father
for whatever reason that day said I have
a twin brother and have a younger
brother so two of us obviously had a
license at the time and my dad said I
want you to take me to the doctor
tomorrow and I don't know why he asked
me to do it not my other brother or
whatever but he asked me to do it so I
Drive him I pick up my grandmother his
mom who doesn't drive never has driven
so I'm driving my dad's in the passenger
seat my grandma's in the back we're
going to his doctor appointment we get
to the doctor and they say hey you're
having a heart attack the prior to that
we all thought a heart attack was let me
grab my chest and then all of a sudden
you drop but it's all the symptoms they
tell you they're not symptoms of a heart
attack you're having the heart attack so
he says I'm sending you over to Johns
Hopkins right now so they call ahead or
whatever I'm driving my dad's in
incredible pain now it's building you
know his chest is tightening I'm a 16
year old that you can't tell anything to
and we're sitting at a stoplight and I'm
getting ready to make a left to the
hospital my father was like it's not
this left I'm like dad it's this left
he's like it's the next left I'm like
dad it's this left he's like god damn it
Ryan it's the next left I'm like it's
this left I know for a fact it's this
left he's like okay
okay I took that heart attack having a
heart attack is the wrong letter it was
the wrong well I not do it as soon as I
made a turn he started watching the
dashboard cuz down the city I gotta go
all the way around the square block sit
at that same light where he could just
[ __ ] me like you piece of [ __ ] at
that take it to the hospital and I mean
he made it obviously that did not kill
him thank God
well I mean he didn't make a budget
didn't make it much long after it didn't
help but man if [ __ ] it I I was just oh
yeah I carry that thanks for making me
feel better about the apple pie but
doing anything for his grave when you go
there yeah every time I I always go get
flowers because he's buried where my
grandmother is she died a few years
after him so I always go right kill him
and I made I made a wrong right you
sprinkle old bay on your flowers I
sprinkle it in my hand I just blow it
into the my dad's headstone is actually
an old bay can and their names around it
holding it [ __ ] crying well I wanted to
go back to Arlington because you had
said before we started that a hobby of
yours you have a certain hobby and
cemeteries it involves cemeteries graves
yeah yeah but can I tell you a quick
story yeah came to me and you're from
Maryland I think you would appreciate
this so my dad also loved baseball so my
dad took me and my family's originally
from Washington DC I was born there all
of my siblings were my dad took me and
my two older brothers to the last
Washington Senators game Wow 1974 I
think I was like 7 years old or whenever
no I think of 71 so I was 4 years old
they didn't play in RFK today where did
they play only remember
was a kid okay you know and then and
then the game ended in a riot they
didn't even get to finish it so I yeah
it's like people ran onto the field and
then I think it ended in grab bases and
stuff yeah yeah exactly so my family
became Baltimore Orioles fans I was an
Orioles fan when I was a kid and one of
my favorite players of all time was Jim
Palmer oh yeah Palmer foresaw Young
Awards handsome guy did this jockey
underwear ads you know God do I know my
ground I'll come back I'll give you a
jockey so so then my family moves
Orlando when I'm 12 and I don't know and
that's like when you really love
baseball and your kid like 12 13 it is
in the newspaper that Jim Palmer is
going to be at our local mall in Orlando
so my dad takes me because I'm a huge
fan and we I stood in line for like you
know an hour 2 hours whatever then we
get to the front he's wasted so we get
to the front and I'm like a little kid
and I go I go Jim could you sign it to
my pal Tom so he signs to my pal Tom and
it was a poster and I went and I taped
it up in my room next to my bed and it
was a promotion for jockey underwear so
I was like 12 handsome baseball player
ever in his underwear and it says to my
pal Tom and how I didn't grow up blow
and minor league baseball player America
[Music]
and it's funny well my well my dad died
I got to look through his stuff and and
and I found my dad saved that Jim Palmer
poster so I I have it it's all like
folded up and you know but it still I've
got to take a picture and that [ __ ] on
Twitter man yeah I should and there's
there and then also I bought a Rodney
Dangerfield concert shirt but at that
show and my dad is like saved it I found
it after he that's cool yeah I so my
grandmother the one that was in the car
when I may or may not have helped kill
my father
ha ha ha but pretty sure she loved Jim
Palmer like it was also she knew it
bothered us cuz that's disgusting
grandma she's like he's handsome and
knows Jackie under guys in every
magazine in America is under it all over
Baltimore even more you know what I mean
like it's everywhere with this guy
steely blue eyes all this [ __ ] my
grandmother loved him so one night she
sees the same thing on the news oh he's
gonna be at the ellingson's mahal doing
a signing and we were going she's like
please if you see him get me an
autograph and tell him I love him and
his jockey on it like shut up grandma
we're not saying that the Jim Palmer so
we get to the mall and we get in line
for her and we get NR you know we like
Jim Palmer till we just don't give a
[ __ ] about the underpants
so my brother gets up there I stand
behind him and he's like you mind
signing this just you know from my
grandma she's a huge fan of yours and
then I just lean over shoulder I was
like and your jockey underwear ads that
I shove him both of you've been to a Jim
Palmer autograph signing at a mall he
was in his [ __ ] underwear that's what
I'm saying I wonder if anybody like took
their pants down and say well the only
autograph signing I've ever been to a
mall was Marky Mark and the Funky Bunch
I'm a threat well hey how short was the
line for the bunch versus the one for
Marky Mark Lyons Freeland my brother was
just
visiting because we got a new baby and
he goes he's telling some stories you
know Maki Wahlberg and I lost it I'm
like dude it's mock Wahlberg or Maki
Maki I would have a Maki Wahlberg and
I'm like that's the only thing I'm ever
gonna call that guy from this point four
mark you over Maki well whatever
happened to the Funky Bunch
there's no doing stunts they still tora
tora Maki Wahlberg so tell us about the
graves I want to hear about the great
yes oh yeah what's that deal I it's I I
like to visit graves of dead people that
I admire I years ago I lived with a
French woman in San Francisco she was
from Paris and the very first time I
went to Paris her mother lived still
lives right next to Pere Lachaise
cemetery where Jim Morrison is buried
but Oscar Wilde is also buried there
Chopin there's a lot of heavyweight
people Edith Piaf is there so I think
that started it and then I in my travels
I just started going to there's a
findagrave.com oh really you can you
have find a grave done that ha ha good
call that I'll write the guy so I've
been to Mickey Mantle's grave Sam
Kinison Evita perón and Buenos Aires
I've been to a lot and in Rome was cool
we saw what's at the pantheon we saw
Raphael's grave Wow and I've been to
Voltaire's do you take pictures you do
give you a tracing yeah Jimi Hendrix
grave I did I took some paper and did a
rubbing thing but if it lighted the same
thing like like Sam Kinison is grave I
brought you know some formula 409 and
some paper kitchen towels and I cleaned
it off so I give its you know sometimes
I don't know it just depends I've done
it through the years I haven't been no
grave in oil you okay I guess it's like
but if it I guess no one's definite my
family that hobby kind of isn't what it
used to be yeah
yeah I've been to Hendrickson Seattle
also went to Bruce and Brandon Lee up
there as well yeah I've been there I've
been to Bruce Lee's grave yeah yeah it's
a nice little Semin tonight yeah there
as far as Cemetery goes real nice nice
up on the hill you a nice little resting
spot on the hill it's alright what are
you gonna do yeah it's kind of shiny
shiny marble Bruce and brave pretty
yep the dragon man that's crazy that's
just crazy you guys first of all been to
to Jim Palmer signings and then you've
also been to the same grave stones just
fir tree did you really do tracing it
either
yeah really did you yeah Jimmy's gravy
yeah go now it's Jimmy forever in our
hearts that's right
charles bukowski x' grave is what's that
place oh my god it's where the ten ends
a forest lawn no that's right here it's
in LA it's not long beach starts with a
P I want to say I don't know why I'm
blanking on this now but Pacific
Palisades yeah or the ten ends now not
to ten it's the one ten were the one
Tenon's
oh not Pasadena the other you know note
somebody by the by the by Long Beach
it's where you already spent the last
ten fifteen years of his life anyway on
Charles Bukowski is grave it says don't
try Wow
sounds right so let me ask you do you
want to be buried or do you want to be
cremated I want to be buried and I
really like now I've been in parishes
where Jim I've been when I first went to
Jim Morrison's grave you could go and
you could sit on it you could touch it
mmm now there's barricades and there's a
guard there at all times but I always
thought it was cool that it was a
destination where people would go and
hang out and like people were smoking
pot and drinking you know other doors
fans so I would like my grave to be like
a gathering spot so if I die with enough
money I would like my tombstone to also
be a jacuzzi
I want to leave enough money where that
the water could be drained you know
because you know a couple of days and
really you know so like not
only could people come and visit my
grave they could sit in the jacuzzi and
hang out I mean jacuzzi yeah you don't
want any koozie tombstone is what I want
dude I think you're honest and thought
about it this is a whole new industry if
kiss can have their own caskets you know
why can't I have a jacuzzi
what do you mean their own casting yeah
you can buy a kiss casket to be buried
in and and and while you're alive you
can use it as a beer clean demilitarized
and use it as a cooler and then you die
your body thought everything yeah they
marketed big [ __ ] out of themselves for
what for decades
one of them's like hey spent more time
on song make up guys like I think you
said I mean I know this is we're talking
about a lot of death here and stuff but
you said you had a near-death experience
yeah this is the most depressing pot guy
just thought I was coming for some crab
and half empty half full you know I mean
where you at
yeah I lived in Amsterdam for five years
I had a late-night talk show on Dutch
television for two years you did yeah I
was like the David Letterman of Holland
there's clips what year was that it was
started in January 2002 gotcha
and then what made you move to Amsterdam
I fell in love with a Dutch girl I
started after I had my sitcom I looked
at my money as my NBC artist grant all
right so wait can we jump back to that
real quick you had a sitcom on NBC
called you said mr. Rhodes
yeah is that online anywhere now I I put
like four episodes up on YouTube I mean
that's that's huge to have your own
sitcom on NBC yeah it was yeah yeah it
was frustrating because I played a
teacher and they gave the kids all the
jokes and I was like the straight man on
my own show so and then it you know and
I couldn't they took like four of my
jokes for the pilot and then after that
I could never get another joke in hmm
so that was very frustrating and when it
ended you know I moved back to New York
City because I had lived there once like
a dog and I had always swore if I had
any money I would live there in style so
I got a rock star apartment in New York
and then I started taking trips to
London and I got in with London the
comedy store specifically and then that
led to gigs all over Europe Asia
Australia and and then I fell in love
with a Dutch girl when I played in
Amsterdam and I moved there and and you
were just traveling out and that was
like your home base and you just yeah
I'm just doing here yeah and I was doing
Europe half the year and then the
state's half the year but I was still
traveling all the time so the
relationship didn't last the girl broke
up with me I was about to move back to
the United States and these people from
this Dutch television network saw me
performing at a comedy club in Amsterdam
to Malheur which is a Jewish kshitij
word for traveling merrymaker
okay back in Old World Europe and they
had the Jewish ghettos there were these
these guys and they were travelling
merrymakers and they would travel around
to the Jewish ghettos and they had songs
and they have any funny stories I think
it's one of the best names for a comedy
club ever yeah tomber so and it's still
there and it's still one of the best
clubs in Amsterdam so I got this
late-night talk show and that girl call
you right back like hey Tom no no no but
it was it's just like I've been thing I
mean I'm from a little town in Florida
how I even lived in Holland and then you
know I mean I don't even speak Dutch and
you know I'm on a television show yeah
it was subtitled in Dutch and all Dutch
people are smart enough to be
interviewed in English so that was like
one of the greatest experiences of my
life and it was really also like a
foreigner experiencing the Netherlands
so every episode there would be a
five-minute film where I would
experience something of Dutch culture
that's cool one day I spent with a Dutch
farmer I got to cover the prime minister
debates I got you know a tour of the red
light district by a
prostitute who does social work for the
for the women getting them health care
and help them pay their taxes everything
was explained to me about the Dutch laws
and everything it was really great so
when that ended if that was not
fortuitous enough this same network let
me be a presenter on a travel program
for a year so you know so now I did one
on st. Petersburg Russia I did a uh I
did one on Peru the Dutch Caribbean so I
mean I really that I love the note
dialed in to Netherlands was so good to
me people think when they think
Amsterdam they think ah drugs and
prostitutes like you know it is so much
more than that it's like so it's a bit
you know you know it's just it's really
artistic they're very progressive people
you know I lived in San Francisco for
years when I went to Holland I thought
that was San Francisco times a thousand
just you know because they implement
progressive ideas into their society so
and I had this wonderful magical life
there so years re5 you say I lived there
for five and so when I was doing the
Travel Show you know III would do it
sporadically so I was still doing
stand-up everywhere and there's this
there was this great Hong Kong China
tour and I did it this one time it was a
Hong Kong and then you played around
China it was booked out of London now I
do a different Hong Kong China gig but
when I did this gig this one tour it was
Hong Kong Bangkok and Tokyo and I had
two weeks off between Bangkok and Tokyo
and the Dutch travel show people said
that if I got certified diving while I
was in Bangkok or in Thailand the next
trip they would send me to the Dutch
Caribbean so and because there was a
travel show they had done Thailand to
death so they told me where to go
I went to the pp Islands you fly like an
hour and a half from Bangkok to Phuket
and then I had to take a boat in and out
in for like four hours into the Bay of
Bengal to get to the pp Islands
was a French resort called Macao and it
was mostly French people I feel like I
haven't been anywhere so it was this
French resort and I was there for a week
I'm just relaxing and it was great and I
thought okay the second week I'll do the
diving thing so the instructor for the
for the diving was this this guy named
Philippe from Montpellier France and he
had all these jailhouse tattoos homemade
tattoos on his arm and he had a ponytail
he had the side of his head shaved he
had a long ponytail but he had the side
shaved so for his mask you know and then
he had he had yellow speedos that
matched his yellow teeth you could smell
the cocaine criminal past on this yeah
there was a reason why this guy was
hiding out in the islands in Thailand so
anyone who I've ever talked to who has
gone diving for a week before you get in
the water you have to study this dive
book you know it's like open water
something book I did not have to study
this book i sat with a very hungover
filly on my first day diving and he went
through the hand signals with me this
means I cannot the buoys this means I
have a love of air love of air okay I'm
underwater oxygen is important a love of
took me a few days to figure out this
means you are low of so when you go
diving you have a buddy you're broken
off into a pair so you have a buddy and
you're constantly checking on your buddy
are you okay buddy and then they give
him the thumbs up back and you just
you're constantly looking out for your
buddy
so the diving class was there was this
English couple mark and Mara and they
had lived in Paris for like five years
they
both spoke fluent French and then this
girl Helene was my partner and she was
from Bordeaux and she worked for Air
France Airlines at the at the ticket
counter at Bordeaux International
Airport so I was single and I thought oh
my god this is love this is man this is
so gonna happen you know I just you know
yeah yeah your mind just just goes crazy
when you're on vacation I was just
picturing living in Bordeaux oh my
eventually and like I'm like smashing
grapes with my feet and picking picking
her up from work at Bordeaux
International Airport and then we we
drive because it's on the coast we drive
to the beach and we throw tennis balls
to our shaggy-dog you know just like
this but in her English wasn't that
wasn't she didn't speak very much
English and I speak four words of French
but so she's my buddy and we're
partnered but Philippe also had a crush
on her so every day I leave his his
underwater flirting was outrageous every
day he would push me aside and then he
would take her and guide her and he's
showing her like all these pretty plants
and plankton and and and I'm by myself
just but it was still being like not yet
so he's shown her he's shown her
everything and it's beautiful and so
it's it's a few days and I'm by myself
and Marc and Mauro they had already been
certified so they were off doing their
thing and everything so a lot of guys
have this like when they like a girl in
a group setting it's this silverback
gorilla mentality he felt the need that
he needed to constantly be insulting me
and granted I'm a sensitive person but
he we had all talked about you know
because so every day the P P islands we
would go have lunch somewhere on some
little there's all these little tiny
Islands where nobody lives and so they
pack a lunch it was really great so
we're eating lunch and it's like perfect
settings and so we talked about what we
did for a living and Mark and Mara they
worked in you know finance and and I
told them that I worked for this Dutch
television program and so he keeps
calling me mr. television so he's
thinking I you know mr. television is
this good enough for you
mr. television and like I'm having the
time of my life I'm in paradise there's
a really cute French girl I have a crush
on I couldn't be happier means like is
this good enough for you mr. television
and then like when you're diving
buoyancy is a big thing buoyancy is the
perfect balance of perfect measures
anyone who's a professional diver you
seem they never use their hands they got
their hands behind their back they're
perfectly parallel and they keep just
there's these two buttons on your vest
and one in Klayton increases the air and
the vest and the other one decreases it
so you can stay so just a professional
diver just lightly hit these little
buttons and they're perfectly parallel
so I can't get it I'm like a novice so
like you know Greatest American Hero
underwater who started out diving you're
like you're flailing your arms trying to
stay balanced and so he keeps yelling at
me mr. television you need to learn the
buoyancy mr. television is this good
enough for you
please mr. television you're being too
rough with the equipment and he's just
like [ __ ] with me about everything
and then on the morning that I almost
died he was really being a dick to me
and he and and I forget what he was
saying I just said I want him my before
shave the sides of his head and like I'm
not killing it's not I'm a bit well I
just said and so we're driving out to
our dive place and because it would take
like you know an hour boat ride to go
where we were Google is a three-day
thing you have to certification I think
it was like five five so he's really
riding my
about something and the day started I
haven't even done anything wrong I'm
awake I'm waking up you know so he's in
case he's missing television this and
and and I and I finally I go hey listen
Philippe I you know I don't know what
problem you have with me I don't know
what I've done to you but I have to be
honest with you men
you know you're making me feel
uncomfortable and I have to trust you
with my life I don't know what I did to
you the the you know has angered you so
much about my being and he just goes oh
mr. American have I hurt your feelings
maybe the al-qaeda has asked me to leave
your body in the ocean today that's mark
the English guy lost his my he stands up
and he goes you are out of order sir
Judy we got mutiny on the ship and then
hit and then that and then him and
Philippe or nose-to-nose and they omen
they're like yelling at each other and
it was this really tense standoff where
they almost fought and and then
everything cools down and we get to our
diving place it was like a really tense
little boat ride out there and that
would be worth he's gonna pull pistol
out and just pop pop pop and dump
everybody well and then so one of the
tanks was bad and so it on the drive out
they said one person wasn't gonna be
able to go diving and then the tie boat
guy is like banging it with a shoe or
something it's announced when we arrived
at our destination that everything's
okay and we can all go diving this in
retrospect it was Russian roulette and I
got the bad tank or I purposefully got
the bad tank so we're down and just like
every other day he pushes me aside and
I'm by myself and all the sudden I start
breathing in water in your lungs don't
want water and there's this button on
your mouth right in front of your mouth
there's these two jets on the side you
hit the button in front of your mouth
and it shoots out whatever is in your
mouth the water it's great I've been
this is like the third day or fourth day
I know I know how this works so I'm
hitting the button and nothing is
happening so then I grabbed the spare
the octopus as its called
and then I get it and it's the same
thing as water so how deep were you
there was a problem with the o-ring so
it's all water into the tubes so we were
only down about 40 feet which isn't that
deep but deep enough to be dangerous and
then you can't care if it's two feet
yeah you can never shoot straight on and
get out that's people really get injured
doing that so he is about I don't know
20 30 feet in front of me with her and
his arm around her showing her [ __ ] and
I I swim to this guy as fast as I can
and to spin him around I actually had to
grab his little ponytail and and and
pull him around and he looks at me and
who would have thought I ever would have
gotten to use the I cannot breathe yeah
signal so I used the kid I cannot
breathe signal and he's looking me right
in the eye and he really seemed to take
his slow sweet time getting this
respirator this octopus octopus bear
right in my mouth and by the time it had
gotten to my mouth I'd held my breath
for a really long time so like and I
mean I don't really still in your mouth
you know I'm holding my breath but so
this thing gets to my mouth like and I
this bark this death bark came out of me
from like my from my from my inner inner
lower intestines I can't even recreate
the sound because it was this death bark
the sound of someone dying and it came
out of me and I and and I thought this
was the last moment of my and I'm like
just I'm gulping on I could feel like
the little tears coming out of the side
of my mouth I'm just like gulping on
this thing and I'm just taking in so
much water and I thought this was the
last moment of my life looking at this
French
faced with bubbles going in front of me
but he guided me up to the top and
obviously I lived and it's really
unfortunate because I am one of the few
Americans who is a Francophile and I
love everything about France and French
people and this fed for that one [ __ ]
like blamed me for all of America's ill
whatever and so I had to wait up on the
boat they had to finish their dive and
then we go back to to our koh pipi to
our island and he and then III he
invited me out to have a beer like in an
hour and I sat on the on the on the
beach and it was a overcast day and and
I watched the sunset it was an overcast
day and it was a pretty mediocre sunset
but I think that was probably the
greatest sunset ever yeah because like
just I was so happy to be alive and just
the met colors I mean there's something
about almost dying that really makes you
appreciate living like for weeks after
that just colors were more vivid smells
sounds just just everything everything
out all your senses were so heightened
so he took me to the little village for
a beer I think he was worried about his
job so like we're talking and everything
and I told him I said Philippe I want
you to know I learned the true meaning
of buoyancy today because this morning
when you said that [ __ ] about al-qaeda
and leave him I bought it in the ocean I
hated your guts and I wanted you to die
and then you saved my life and all is
forgiven
that is true moyens he's right about
that true buoyancy the perfect balance
of perfect moments and what was his
response ah you know he showed me a
picture of his wife who was uh he was
about to cheat on with your now tell me
a picture of his wife and his kid who
was a black woman living in Montpelier
and their their kid and you know he
can't go back there
or he couldn't go back there so I mean I
guess he was trying to show me that he
was Hugh
and he had a heart even though you know
he's scumbag and he's definitely trying
to [ __ ] every woman that comes into his
class so then there was a little bar a
little tiki hut bar on the resort and I
go there and there's there's Helene and
so I go talk to her and and you know her
English isn't that good my French isn't
that good and I'm trying to make small
talk with her and I go so small I go so
what's what's the first thing you're
gonna do when you get back to Bordeaux
and she goes make love to my boyfriend
[Laughter]
okay what's the second thing you're
gonna do she goes there is no second
thing you know be careful who you almost
die for because they might not give a
[ __ ] okay so this dive now you're
certified to go where where are they
sending you next well and then I had to
go one more day okay to get certified
and then so they hit are they graduated
the French girl got her certificate
because mark Amaro was certified so I
have to go one more day and then it's
these professional divers and they want
to see sharks in caves well and I
thought I need to go or else I'll never
go diving ever again in my life to break
the fear so I went back the next day and
and then these morons are like looking
in these caves for these like swimming
in them they're these little caves and
they're these little sharks and they're
actually sleeping so but I didn't know
that you hear sharks I'm yeah
everything's I really awake shark than a
sleeping shark because I feel like if
you woke asleep you are [ __ ] yeah you
know I mean are you out of your [ __ ]
mind I'm a shark where's awake shocked
when I came I just ate one but you look
but IIIi challenged my fear cuz I knew
I'd never do it again and then you know
yeah hey cute shark in a cave [ __ ] off
and then so I got certified and then the
the Dutch travel show sent me to Kura
Sal and Aruba and I got to go diving in
Curacao
and that was pretty cool they filmed me
swimming through a shipwreck that's cool
that's cool
damn new [ __ ] it was tiny it was like
the USS minnow you know totally but you
could swim through the the windshield
that wasn't there anymore all right so
how many countries do you think you've
done stand-up it oh I've never counted
we were I have a map on my wall I don't
know a lot yeah
and if you lived it after Amsterdam did
you move to any other countries there's
just us and answered after Amsterdam I I
moved to LA for a couple years and in in
retrospect it was great because my dad
was living in Anaheim and I got to spend
a lot of time with my dad in Anaheim and
our while I was living in LA and then
that's I was paying rent on a place I
was never at and I was out of the
country half the year so that's when I
decided to throw everything into storage
so that was ten years ago Wow and you've
bounced around mostly Europe for ten
years I know I you know I did five
months in Europe last year a month in
Asia and then six months all over the
states the year before that I did a
month in Australia a month in New
Zealand three months in Europe so yeah
it always depends that's [ __ ] that's
great and then you know constantly
Chicago San Francisco DC everywhere in
America what would you say what do you
think's the craziest thing you've seen
out there not just comedy but the
craziest thing you've come across what
about the craziest show I mean is it
good it's got to be different somewhere
else you know I've seen I've seen human
levels of debauchery in London that were
probably unparalleled - my brother lives
now I know on them yeah yeah it's still
1984 there with cocaine and people
partying and stuff it's pretty cool man
I think you know you talked about like
facing your fear but I think a lot of
people just to move travel and take the
I mean just doing stand-up in an and a
different venue can be scary let alone
another country with a whole different
population of people that view calm
differently then how do you even know
what they really after yes well for me
that's the most exciting thing to go to
because like what's what people laugh at
in England is different than what they
laugh at in Ireland I mean you got your
core material that did is funny and it's
gonna work everywhere but you do have to
modify it kind of on the spot you know
and then Holland is completely different
because it's not their first language
and then there's great gig in Paris you
know and then like Hong Kong Beijing
Shanghai you know you're playing these
all expat shows a lot of expats but
there's also a lot of Chinese people
that grew up in Canada u.s. Australia
England and or went to university in
those places and our English language
comedy lovers so it's not always
expatriates I really like Kuala Lumpur
Malaysia and that's all like
dark-skinned local people you know
that's great man
well we're right about there man I this
has been it's been a lot of fun now are
you gonna bring up the crib it's getting
ready to come on out it's come on well
you uh one more time please with your
Twitter your website anything underscore
Tom Rhodes Tom Rhodes dotnet is my
website Tom Rhodes radio is my podcast
which is on all things comedy check that
out this is awesome man thanks for
coming on now this is wonderful yeah
thanks guys
as always Jay Larson call me calm Jay
Larson comedy on all social media Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram Facebook
Ryan psycho calm we'll talk to you all
next Tuesday and I might come on we'll
talk about happier topics